O!Sapiens Expert: Привет?
Diana Paritskaya: Здравствуйте?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мион?
Diana Paritskaya: Пока не умерла?
O!Sapiens Expert: Низкая, планка?
O!Sapiens Expert: Надеюсь, что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Продлиться долго?
Diana Paritskaya: Хотелось бы?
Diana Paritskaya: У тебя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Суши. Да, по разному последние, конечно, пару месяцев, без Детс были сложены сейчас. Хоть. Это морально, немного, как то чуть подпустило но здоровье еще шутается.
O!Sapiens Expert: Так, что, конечно, не прям?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что это дикая неопределенность. Очень Прям бьет по?
O!Sapiens Expert: По всем. Аспектам?
O!Sapiens Expert: Когда надо платить за квартиру это какой, Птак Блять?
O!Sapiens Expert: На счете. Денег Нет, Кысука?
Diana Paritskaya: Понимаемо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тяжело?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Diana Paritskaya: Говорю. Понимаемо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Поэтому конечно, такое непростой период.
O!Sapiens Expert: Как минимум?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хотя бы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Солнце?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что нибудь здоров?
Diana Paritskaya: А Ты в какой части испании?
O!Sapiens Expert: Барселоне?
O!Sapiens Expert: Каталония?
Diana Paritskaya: Я была там?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тридцать, два ложах. Уверят?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ультрафилетовый индекс, десять?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это. Юнис?
Diana Paritskaya: Спр?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Тут?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тсни. Спехтс?
O!Sapiens Expert: Когда, похоже, это дальше, будет жарче.
O!Sapiens Expert: Скрея то, сама?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чем, Привет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кать. Ты. Тут с нами да.
FANATIC Agency: Месту?
O!Sapiens Expert: Закажи, Чайнич?
FANATIC Agency: Катя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Просто проверить, что ты здесь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Микрофон. Выключи?
O!Sapiens Expert: Камертор?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кать. Музей не слышаем и, не, видим?
O!Sapiens Expert: Поп?
FANATIC Agency: Отцепилось. Совсем?
O!Sapiens Expert: По понятным причинам?
Diana Paritskaya: Не сейчас. Она попросила. Сык Конферт?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тек?
O!Sapiens Expert: Раз раз?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кэти, Скажи Ничего?
Екатерина Шалонская: Я простоедини?
Екатерина Шалонская: Ось?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага, давай, теперь слышу напасибо?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так, че Друзья, у, нас. С вами, давно не было разговоров?
O!Sapiens Expert: В Четырех конец вроде выбралась выдалось. Возможность поговорить давайте воспользуемся Этой. Возможностью! А вы Сами. Видите что на, сейчас это не самое простое время, но это не значит что, как, это деятельность. Не продолжается.
O!Sapiens Expert: Из хороших новостей. Мы начали получать поступление от тех?
O!Sapiens Expert: Проектов, которые ну эти, маленькие простые, и, мы, сейчас. Будем использовать деньги для того, чтобы учать, закрывать те задолженности которые есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы все еще ждем и надеемся но, Тут понятно абдет еще. Будет на наши коман исходки но, Концептуально да. Мы. Рассчитываем на то, что магнит произведет но, тут?
O!Sapiens Expert: Неизвестно, нет никакого точного понимания потому что, мы это рассчитывали мая.
O!Sapiens Expert: Конец июня, явно сейчас, ничего не произойдет?
O!Sapiens Expert: В лучшем случае в июле ну И, Понятно другие аспекты, которые с, этим связаны эта работа. Том. Сэджерс и Так Далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но концептуально. В любом случае, не самое простое и ни самое легкое время пытаемся. Выплатить из этого?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пиздеца, Как можем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но, при. Этом, конечно, мы продолжаем работу и, тут надо понять да как мы можем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Взаимодействовать эффективно. Я понимаю, что там может быть, что накопились, какие, то аспекты которые надо проговорить.
O!Sapiens Expert: Было, бы класно. Но Нам так же надо еще поговорить с вами про партнерскую модель, как таковую, и про то, как она сейчас работает, или может быть, не работает, может быть, про ваше тоже наблюдение.
O!Sapiens Expert: Для того чтобы мы дальше поняли, Как мы можем? Перестроить формат взаимодействия? Может быть, может быть, сам подход, может быть, система мотивации, и так, далее. Тому, что ну, пока партнерская модель, выглядит как, у. Вас есть определенные преференции в виде партнерского процента но концептуально?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как будто уровень ответственности он радикальным образом не изменился если сравнивается Условно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Зовем? Это. Стратегом. Такого. Среднестатистического. Крупного агентства в россии и тут Надо. Понять. Да как мы можем. Это, поженить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Для того, чтобы это работало или, если вдруг это не работает, то придумать какую то новую конфигурацию которая, бы устроила всех?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это Краткое водное?
O!Sapiens Expert: Антон У. Тебя было чудо заготовлено. Что, ты, Хотел поднять?
FANATIC Agency: На самом деле, ну ключевое влад проговорил. Хочется обсудить, как вы, это, видите как, мы, это, видим чтобы новоприсудство, экранизировали все в. Ожиданиях?
FANATIC Agency: Мых прокопилось, какое то, количество?
FANATIC Agency: У всех со всех сторон?
FANATIC Agency: Плюс Ключевая. История почему. И? Мы сейчас ходим эту тему поднять но вы. Видели, и ночь, встречка до массаж встречались что?
FANATIC Agency: Понимания. А если мы, каким, то образом интегрируемся в их понимание партнера то, человек который, биллинг Приводит дождь?
FANATIC Agency: Человек, в которого просто абсолютно другая. Я?
FANATIC Agency: Задача внутри?
FANATIC Agency: И, ну, нам, бы хотелось с каким то образом это выравнять и?
FANATIC Agency: Тод?
FANATIC Agency: Предгорец, предгорец, В всем было все было комфортно.
FANATIC Agency: Я, ну, Я, уверен что, мы, давно, за сегодня это не, сделаем?
FANATIC Agency: Зараз. Ну. Как, виниму, чтоб, мы с вами в четверг подняли от, разговор?
FANATIC Agency: Только в четвертого?
Diana Paritskaya: Как мы хотим построить это обсуждения? Если у вас есть видение, расскажите его. Нам.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне бы не сказал, что она есть. Какой комната? Сформулированы?
FANATIC Agency: Ну? Ключевое? Что мне.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Так ключевой мне. Кажется. Мы с, вами, затрагивали в кейптауне и Только, Кажется что, это модель на которую, и надо, переходить?
FANATIC Agency: До своя. Партнерская. Модель началась с того, что?
FANATIC Agency: У нас была небольшая кладная часть, и до какие то существенные проценты, которые мотивировали внутри проекты. Вести.
FANATIC Agency: Сейчас кажется что, логично, и правильно перейти к той модели которая больше приднеста на рынке.
FANATIC Agency: Это?
FANATIC Agency: Нормальным образом?
FANATIC Agency: Увеличить?
FANATIC Agency: Окладную. Часть?
FANATIC Agency: Сделать ее рыночный и в бонусной части переехать но какой. То другой систему, мотивации которая не, связана напрямую с биллингом на первую Продажу?
FANATIC Agency: Есть там. Оставить, может быть проценты с до продажи. Других. Услуг Какое то внутрие? Включение в агентскую деятельность и так, далее?
FANATIC Agency: То есть, например, чудесный, материал написали. Про теорию поколений катя вот Сейчас, Вебинар закончила и Так далее, то есть, Очевидно что все эти вещи должны также поощряться финансово?
FANATIC Agency: Не скорее приехать на эту модель?
FANATIC Agency: Изменить?
FANATIC Agency: Окладную, часть ее увеличить?
FANATIC Agency: Сейчас искать ей вчера и с тобой день сейчас. Мы говорили о том что вы вернемся с, трейками в которых будет зафиксирован. Рост и изменения, как раз по окладным частям?
FANATIC Agency: Которые прозрачные, которые, понятным образом, на котором нужно влиять?
FANATIC Agency: И набор того, чтобытри. Дополнительно.
FANATIC Agency: Монетизируется. Что, в общем, как можно влиять? Но а какой то бонус? Ты? Составляешь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, в дополнении потому, что антон?
FANATIC Agency: Пример.
O!Sapiens Expert: Сказал, два разашло?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сейчас!
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты? Нас слышишь видишь?
FANATIC Agency: Какая Важная информация что, Надо с двух устройств сразу?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но лучше. Да, дополнения. К тому что, антон, сказал Есть еще, один, момент относительно мотивации который уважен просто, для, понимания относительно?
O!Sapiens Expert: По крайней мере того?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не знаю подходо. К обсуждению и структурированию системы, которой, мы сейчас обсуждаем это. То, что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Текущий формат мотивации финансовой мотивации. Перевощить. Он. К, сожалению показывает, свою дисфункциональность в том плане что он ориентирован, на изоляцию и индивидуальную работу и. У нас получается что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну несмотря. На, то что, мы, вроде хотим культивировать такой более командный. Подход, у нас, получается что как, это, каждый гребет за свое, И это абсолютно не работает. Как показывает практика весь это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Само, по себе не стимуть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Желание двигаться в направлении более командной работы.
O!Sapiens Expert: Противоречит текущей системе мотивации, которая идет, условно, говоря в другое, направление и, задача которая, сейчас там стоит перед нами придумать, как раз, таки тот подход, который будет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Все же подкреплять именно командные взаимодействие, нежели индивидуальную работу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чтобы мы могли именно все, же Как то больше колаборить? Во первых?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вторых именно действовать как. Более Слаженная команда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нежели. Как какие, то отдельно взяты индивиды. И Ну, Вот текущие сейчас. По, Крайней, мере как мне видется проблема там не, знаю. С нашими?
O!Sapiens Expert: Процессами культуры. И там, в том числе и, так далее что. Как, это каждый сам за, себя каждый, сам, по, себе и все, таки, раскиданные. И Вот вот, мы как то существуем, и как бы это существовало, Это понятно, как бы в этого есть причины.
O!Sapiens Expert: Но мы, собственно, пытаемся это поменять для того, чтобы это поменять. Одна. Из Основных Загроздок как, раз таки заключается в том. Чтобы, согласовать систему мотивации чтобы, она подкрепляла тот вектор который, мы сами себе задали?
O!Sapiens Expert: И это пока больше, наверно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Какой то тизер нежели что, то, конкретное потому, что, я не могу сейчас вам взять и, принести какие, то конкретные?
O!Sapiens Expert: Из разряда системы. Как Это будет выглядеть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Концептуально?
O!Sapiens Expert: Почеркнул?
O!Sapiens Expert: Фокус?
O!Sapiens Expert: Будет больше направлен на даже финансовую мотивацию. Именно через призму командного взаимодействия.
O!Sapiens Expert: И, ну, естественно, глубину, погружения, в?
O!Sapiens Expert: Клиент?
Diana Paritskaya: Ну пока звучит очень абстрактно. Как Бы мы все понимаем что, как, то эта мотивация будет меняться своей системой, будет, меняться, пока просто нечь понятно, тогда как это обсуждать.
Diana Paritskaya: Мой основной поинт чтобы, мы не стали зарабатывать меньше чем, зарабатывали раньше?
Diana Paritskaya: Все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тут будет все зависить. Ну как бы если. Мы Говорим про окладную часть то будет слон, и фикс который?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ноу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не меньше. Текущего процент будет зависить от ряда факторов в. Остальном я. Не могу тебе сказать что это, будет исключительное повышение естественно, но, Оно так не работает потому, что, все зависит от ряда факторов?
Diana Paritskaya: В смысле?
FANATIC Agency: Лента?
O!Sapiens Expert: В прямом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Смотри бо, ты, возьмешь свой оклад там за какой то период, у, тебя, будет варироваться?
O!Sapiens Expert: Двадцать второй, двадцать третий, двадцать четвертый, двадцать пятый, и. Нет такого что, мы меняем мотивацию. Исключительно из принципа того что, У тебя будет только расти. Оклад?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так не работает, потому что процент будет зависить от ряда факторов?
O!Sapiens Expert: В зависимости от взаимодействия с командой в зависимости, от каких, то не знаю дополнительных активностей и Так далее, это Все будет складываться в определенную сумму?
O!Sapiens Expert: Эта сумма, в идеале должна быть достаточно комфортной для тебя чтобы, ну, ты, Продолжала, Свою, деятельность и развивалась?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но как это будет По факту? Это, в том числе Будет завести от тебя?
FANATIC Agency: Коротко Говоря как, сейчас зафиксировали мы, увеличим?
FANATIC Agency: Гладную часть?
FANATIC Agency: И дадим прозрачную систему, того, как можно самостоятельно повлиять на бонусную часть, она не будет зависиться.
FANATIC Agency: Прихода того или одного клиента, и так далее.
FANATIC Agency: Это меню мы. Еще не прорабатывали?
FANATIC Agency: Проработаем, потом вместе с Вами. Также в четвер Созвонимся и посмотрим?
FANATIC Agency: В идеали?
FANATIC Agency: За то, что Влад сказал?
FANATIC Agency: Это точно не умечение, никакое, и так далее но. А, то насколько, это будет больше будет влиять на прямую то Если это будет прозрачная система, И ты на нее напряму можешь?
FANATIC Agency: Билет?
FANATIC Agency: Да, Будешь, то, или нет. Это Вообще, зависит только от тебя?
FANATIC Agency: Так на рынке. Это примерно у всех и устроено?
FANATIC Agency: Хочешь получать больше? Кей? Призладно себя. Больше. По одногрузкей. Губинаров. Провела?
FANATIC Agency: Участвовала в развитии команды. Еще Какие то вещи сделала и, это все финансово будет пошляться?
Diana Paritskaya: Главное, чтобы итоговая сумма которая, человек на позиции стратега мелвозможность заработать, была, не, меньша чем то, что у, нас, было раньше. Я. Ну. Как, бы, понимаю что очевидно, это зависит?
Diana Paritskaya: Как бы, от наших усилий?
Diana Paritskaya: Просто. Ну. Как, вы надо понимаешь если. Услуга Горы мы идем, вниз то, как, бы, какой смысл вообщает все продолжать?
FANATIC Agency: Дах.
FANATIC Agency: Да, да?
FANATIC Agency: Нет это неделем. Вниз?
O!Sapiens Expert: Будет зависит тебя. Диана?
FANATIC Agency: Да, Плюс, там есть месяцы, то есть, мы смотрим например, в, погоду среднюю, зарплату там. Были очевидно месяцы когда, просто?
FANATIC Agency: Прилетало несколько проектов. И Вы в месяц. Получали одну довольно там значительную большую бонусную часть?
FANATIC Agency: То есть, мы не берем такие месяцы Мы, скорее, смотрим в среднее которая, была погода?
Diana Paritskaya: Я тоже смотрю средняя. Погода?
FANATIC Agency: Вот окей да. Да, здесь, да. Да. Здесь, Здесь, вы. Родились?
Diana Paritskaya: Очевидно, на те месте?
Diana Paritskaya: Влад по поводу, того, что все будет зависить от меня. Спасибо, А Я это понимаю.
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер! Это главное?
Diana Paritskaya: Ну. Да но, как, будто хочется как бы, обсуждаться это не. Только в контексте что вот, сколько ты. Заработаешь будет зависит только от тебя. Хочется раз мы что то, обсуждаем систему, какой то мотивации, то, и на какие то факты, операция?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну Да Так, мы. Же придем с конкретикой и, это обсудим?
Diana Paritskaya: Ты. Так просто сказал что, типа антон, говорит Что мы, будем, увеличивать кратно типа оклад?
Diana Paritskaya: А Ты Говоришь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кратное, кажи. Антон. Так. Не. Говорил. Что Мы будем кратно увеличить. Оклад?
Diana Paritskaya: Хорошо. Мы будем увеличивать оклад?
FANATIC Agency: Увеличивать. Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Некратна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Такого не было.
FANATIC Agency: Да?
Diana Paritskaya: Но я тоже. Сейчас могу продираться к словам. Давайте.
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай мы будем все же оперировать точными формулировками, чтобы у нас были прозрачные ожидания.
O!Sapiens Expert: Это очень важное слово которое радикальным, образом меняет смысл?
Diana Paritskaya: Хорошо. Если мы говорим про увелечение оклада тогда, сколько это планируется?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы вернемся с конкретики?
FANATIC Agency: Да, мы вернемся этого то, чем с, вами проговаривали одна встречу. В которой, сариной, был?
FANATIC Agency: Были. Мы привяжем наклад к треку, и к грейдам?
FANATIC Agency: Что там, и все увесьет?
FANATIC Agency: Восьма ровно для. Этого система. Грегирования дела?
Diana Paritskaya: Так, окей. А, Тогда, сейчас мы что, хотим обсуждать?
FANATIC Agency: Сейчас мы встретились просто проговорить, что у нас будет это изменения, чтобы, ну как, то, прозрачном бровару?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что будет боль. Прозрачный. Ожидаемо?
FANATIC Agency: Да, Да, да. Если есть, Какие то, ожидания скорее выравнятся на них и поговорить?
Екатерина Шалонская: Я правильно принимаю бонусную часть. Сейчас ожидаемо входит А. Маркетинговая. Активность б. Какое. То типа не? Знаю?
FANATIC Agency: Ожидать?
Екатерина Шалонская: Внутренние семинары. Или там девочек. Я воспи всес, что нибудь научу считать?
Екатерина Шалонская: Или книгу, расскажу, или как это должна работать?
FANATIC Agency: Эй, тебешая. Это. Вся внешняя активность маркетинговая это, вся внутренняя, активность, маркетинговая, И как, я, говорил, мы. Сейчас, смотрим, И здесь. Скорее советуемся с Тим Жежерс?
FANATIC Agency: Как оставить бонусы по Удачно завершенному клиенту и по проекту, который продолжается на следующей шаге?
FANATIC Agency: То, еще, словно, клиент зашел. Первый.
FANATIC Agency: Первая, его оплата на. Очевидно скорее?
FANATIC Agency: Прилетает, потому что там, его, кто то продал этот проект.
FANATIC Agency: Но если клиент уходит на следующие этапы если, он?
FANATIC Agency: Окей ему нравится работа. Со Стратегом который ведет проект если он ему доверяет, если продают следующий этап очевидно, что это уже заслуга стратега и, Там можно вот в следующих до продажах?
FANATIC Agency: Рассчитывать на то, что там, останется. Бонусная часть.
Екатерина Шалонская: Так до продажи внешней маркетинговой что. Ты. Имел Ввиду под внутренними маркетинговыми вот я тут не? Поняла?
Екатерина Шалонская: Или оговорились?
FANATIC Agency: Это я говорился это. Красти Вещи которые. Связаны, скорее с внутренними семинарами и обучением чему то, и, так далее?
Екатерина Шалонская: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: То есть, те вещи, которые, напряму вы влияют на развитие. Всех команд?
FANATIC Agency: Бонусную часть за работу с клиентом я. Тоже оставим тоже только повторюю что, это не?
FANATIC Agency: Мне только будет сейчас?
FANATIC Agency: До Сберег заходит. Клиент?
FANATIC Agency: И все прыгают на него, только, исходя из того, сколько он денег отов заплатить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей давайте Ещем Проговорим про один важный блог который я не знаю, мы вроде время, от, времени, проговорим но всякий случай еще раз, чтобы было, как то чуть больше понятно, и прозрачно и, так далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: У нас есть. Женя, у нас есть Арина, и Женя Она в перучите Отвечает, передо мной и она, отвечает за всю операционную, составляющую, будь то коммерческие проекты будь?
O!Sapiens Expert: То выставление предложений сопровождения, закрытие, там, где то видение проектов. Если нет, то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Условно в ее починении дальше. Это. Уже лера?
O!Sapiens Expert: И Аня, и Ну, там, еще параллельно Взаимодействия с бухгалтером да Моей Сестрой Андреевой?
O!Sapiens Expert: И там?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это ее. Часть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Соответственно, со всеми Вопросами. Можно по этим?
O!Sapiens Expert: Блоком. Идти Если необходимо. К. Жене, Если вдруг, что, то она придет ко мне В остальном Что Касается Продукта?
O!Sapiens Expert: Наслеги. С Точно помню, что у нас есть. Арина и Арина курирует все проекты с точки зрения их ведения с точки зрения их качества?
O!Sapiens Expert: Если в Арины есть дальше, какие то вопросы найдет контону, и их, решает но концептуально, если у. Вас есть какие то, вопросы по?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я не знаю продукту по проекту если. Нужна. Какая. То, поддержка помощи что мне, кажется, перчая, к которому стоит идти Это Арина, Но она не должна делать там за вас руками и, она вас все же поддерживает?
O!Sapiens Expert: И это тоже важно помнить и понимать Но давайте здесь. Тоже еще просто.
O!Sapiens Expert: Поймем может, быть, что то, где, то непонятно, какие, то границы недоразмыты, размытые или, недо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Уточнены, или, может, быть непонятно там как, с, кем взаимодействовать кто. За. Чего отвечает но что? Такое Щение что как то время от времени это всплывает и?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. Разом, с мы. С действу давайте это проговорим.
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну, Типу, мне, иногда кажется, что если, арина Не Делает Руками то вот, сегодня ее навстречи не было и я не видела смысла изначального обсуждения Почему она должна быть сегодня на? Встрече с пионером?
Екатерина Шалонская: Мы отцелали, типа, они прислали нам нейминге шесть страниц красиво описанных.
Екатерина Шалонская: Очень плохих неймингов вот ну простите.
Екатерина Шалонская: И надо было собрать им?
Екатерина Шалонская: Антон. Не Слышно презентацию?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот.
FANATIC Agency: Та нет, он то, поделись поделись. Наременками то Интересно.
Екатерина Шалонская: Ареалы Днк?
Екатерина Шалонская: Еще была. Форум.
Екатерина Шалонская: Но их не прислали но анекде То Рассматривают И квартал с арт, большими буквами посередине?
FANATIC Agency: Глядач?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да чтоб ты понимал креативный акционер Но ладно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Екатерина Шалонская: И вообще у меня вообще возник вопрос, Почему было обсуждение? Зачем Арина? На эту встречу Они прислали нам шесть страниц и мне, надо было просто. Типа Эйч. Страниц Упаковать. В презентацию потому что, шесть, страниц, никто, читать не, будет?
Екатерина Шалонская: И Пионеры. Сказали. Ой. Вы, Так, красиво собираете презентажки соберите нам презентажки?
Екатерина Шалонская: И Типа. Мы сегодня. Сорок минут обсуждали из разряда, Но вот здесь, мне слово не нравится вот здесь. Наверно Чуть чуть структуру переделать, а. Вот здесь типа, добавьте. Обязательно что, у нас там не только там офисы но, и культурные пространства вот. Конкретно в этом предложении, Несмотря на то, что вы сказали, это на. Три слайдал раньше?
Екатерина Шалонская: Нато есть и у меня возник вопрос, о чем вообще обсуждалась. Зачем Арина Там? Изначально. Вот?
Екатерина Шалонская: Как бы зачем ее привлекать на она? Сегодня не пришла только, потому, что, у пионера Не было другого слота?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот, наверно. Так?
Екатерина Шалонская: А Если бы она пришла, я, типа, я засматривала, это, как пустую трату времени. Я на. Сам. Деле рассматриваю сам. Звоночек немного. Как, пустую. Трату Времени учитывая что, у, них есть?
Екатерина Шалонская: Презентажка, со всеми комментариями?
Екатерина Шалонская: А меня просто сорок. Пять минут. Увели. По презентажке с комментариями, то есть, иногда кажется что, есть, какой, то микроменеджмент каких то таких вещей?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
O!Sapiens Expert: Со стороны арины?
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну типа, знаешь, это. Мы, зовем, арину. На Все Встречи С клиентами то что мы. Зовем арину, на все встречу С. Клиентом?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот, наверное, это так А типа, насколько вообще Арине будут полезны? Нужно там знать потому, что, это какие, то, микроправки типа, или какие то иторации?
Екатерина Шалонская: И ничего значительного это в проекте. Не меняет и воще, ничего не меняет типа это просто?
Екатерина Шалонская: Втраты ее времени в, том, числе?
Екатерина Шалонская: Как бы?
Екатерина Шалонская: И плюс человек, когда вас. Итак. Немного, на звонке я Просто не, понимаю зачем на, такие вещи?
FANATIC Agency: Сто проценту?
Екатерина Шалонская: Типа. Ее мучите. Я понимаю, если там, как, то направление определяем. Гипотезу. Презентуем?
Екатерина Шалонская: Но А. Там?
Екатерина Шалонская: Вот такая штука Вообще Была?
Екатерина Шалонская: Иногда просто есть. Мы Зовем арину По то что, мы зовем, всегда арину?
Екатерина Шалонская: Может, надо. Не Знаю какой то рэндж Сделать Или Там, смотреть в конкретных случаях но не жить, по этому правилу по молчанию?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
FANATIC Agency: Сто, процентов?
FANATIC Agency: Тоже сто процентов но, Это важно. Что то, проговорила я вопрос. Оставил но, не, ренчно?
FANATIC Agency: Это правда, Похоже, на микроменеджмент?
FANATIC Agency: Я сделаю предположение, что то, может быть, лера, тревожится, за пионер или она, подумала что, это. Будет лучше для встречи данного конкретном случае чтобы, быстрее?
FANATIC Agency: Но?
FANATIC Agency: Ты ведешь проект ты знаешь этого клиента? Тут клиент что то презентует? Я? Не, знаю, зачем порядна, должна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сейчас можно попросить здесь А Ну кто, принял решение что ории, не надо быть на этом зонке?
Екатерина Шалонская: Никто, не принял. Типа. Пионер Принял решение, они. Хотели созвониться конкретно они. Вчера Вечером написали ти позвонимся сегодня.
Екатерина Шалонская: И арены. Просто слот не было, поэтому я. Сегодня там не было.
FANATIC Agency: Не не влад спрашивать а, Кто Решил что в, этот слот надо чтобы арина, попала?
Екатерина Шалонская: А Должна?
Екатерина Шалонская: А там был сразу вопрос. Лера. Задавала автоматический типа. По Моему сейчас чтобы, не собрать?
Екатерина Шалонская: Она Тэгнула Меня и, арину с фразой. Типа.
Екатерина Шалонская: Привет Леди, Артем, Попросил Минисинг?
Екатерина Шалонская: Воткну. Нам, куда, имуте мне. Кажется. Просто Тыкнулось по, типа что всегда, двое?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, от?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, да?
Екатерина Шалонская: Может, из этого. Правила надо, как ну типа сни, им, рукаво?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. Я, думаю здесь, надо лери уточнить что ну ариня с, лерой, наверно Может, быть даже Проговорить, но давай, мы это донесем До Арины, как минимум и долеры, в том числе чтобы, мы правда согласовали чтобы, не, было такого что, мы извем на каждую встречу, потому что ну правду в. Этом нет. Необходимости?
FANATIC Agency: Надо ты?
O!Sapiens Expert: Совершенно правильно. Подметила, что, ну, как бы это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Последрат времени?
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну, Да то, есть тепло?
Екатерина Шалонская: Зачем нужно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но важный момент спасибо что, Подсветило Как минимум, это, может облегчить жизнь ариня.
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну Да, на, просто на. Каждом. Проекте и, на всех проектах на всех, звонках, типа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Оверкилл?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Спасибо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай, мы прине подсветим?
FANATIC Agency: Да, это ваша молда.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ми проговорим с лератором?
FANATIC Agency: Я думал, что я, думаю, даже кто, больше не Оринья. Она. Далее, женя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, но, это, наверное Арине Надо с лерой поговорить в первую очередь да ну и. Женю, понятно тоже, но, просто, эктому, что?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Видимо, ну, То, есть как, это кроссфункциональный, диалог. Тоже где. То, видимо сломался?
FANATIC Agency: Да, да?
Екатерина Шалонская: На то банке мы пофиксили эту штуку. Мы, в какой то момент я сказала а вам, аренджений вообще нужно сидеть на наших внутренних звонках С Девочками Где мы, типа Мы трендеры, сбираем?
Екатерина Шалонская: Наверно, нет в итоге ну, как бы здесь, еще вот, этот вопрос ну. Да кто куда ходит он еще, не, до конца? Решел?
Екатерина Шалонская: Кашт?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Давайте, этого поднимим Мое?
O!Sapiens Expert: Решим. Что, было?
O!Sapiens Expert: Больше, Оптимизируйте меньше, Правда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пустою?
O!Sapiens Expert: Максима?
Diana Paritskaya: А можно обозначить такой момент, из того, что я слышу, то, что влад ты говорил по сути. Все вопросы, которые возникают по продукту этой корения, вопрос который возникает, по какой то операционной истории. Это к жени, то есть, по сути, к тебе, и к антону Вопросов.
Diana Paritskaya: Типа. Нет, То есть, они автоматически. Туда идут.
O!Sapiens Expert: Завище с того, какие вопросы концептуально я бы сказал, что так?
Diana Paritskaya: А ваших взаємодельствиях с Командой Как складывается?
O!Sapiens Expert: С командой. Ты. Мешкат в. Широком смысле?
Diana Paritskaya: Ну. Да, типа, ну, то. Есть, просто в таком, как бы, ключа, получается мы условно общаемся только на, Командных, сфотках?
Diana Paritskaya: Насколько я понимают?
O!Sapiens Expert: Почему у нас есть понедельничная встреча, Когда мы встречаемся регулярно, все вроде?
FANATIC Agency: Я в проектах еще каких то, участвую?
Diana Paritskaya: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вопрос. Я больше слона На Бэкэнде, Я там не знаю с. Бухгалтерии какие то. Вопросы решаю там жени, какие то, вопросы? Решаю я?
FANATIC Agency: Нужен.
O!Sapiens Expert: В принципи, исторический. С вами не то чтобы много взаимодействовал?
O!Sapiens Expert: То, что я не лезу в продукты.
O!Sapiens Expert: Не мое ну. Типа, ям, не, говорил, как делать продукты я не? Давал? Обратную. Связь по вашей работе ну что ты?
O!Sapiens Expert: Продукты, отнимая зона, ответственности?
FANATIC Agency: Да, Одна, у меня другая сейчас. История мы, как, раз брали арину, для Того, Чтобы операционно, она просто включена во все проекты. Лучшее, То есть, проекты, там, на азвуки о Присутствую. Понимают Что то происходит?
FANATIC Agency: Кусово Присутствую. Понимающе происходят, все предпринимательские бренды я. Веду. Интервью понимаю что происходит, есть проекты. В, которых, я просто не включен?
FANATIC Agency: То есть, там, условно, т, банк. Если. Катя. Придет что то, спросить?
FANATIC Agency: Я могу, что то посоветовать по методологии, но я не могу посоветовать конкретно по этому проекту.
FANATIC Agency: И вот те вещи которые, нужны, по?
FANATIC Agency: Методологии. По подходу по продукту?
FANATIC Agency: Я всегда открыт. В любой момент. Вы можете приходить?
FANATIC Agency: По поводу деталей ведения проекта и. Просто него все Проекты Включен?
FANATIC Agency: Плюс. Сейчас. Ну. Для, Меня основное, и это, мы сегодня проговорим это в пятницу это запустить. Новый. Проект. Седжерс.
FANATIC Agency: Первая и, мы сейчас делаем предпродажу. Мы. До?
FANATIC Agency: Написали, на формулировали. Продукт. И сейчас, будем переходить к его маркетингу на. Следующей. Неделе встреча по. Маркетингу. Этого Продукта?
FANATIC Agency: И вторая история. Это продукции. Чар. Бренда вей чар Платформе.
FANATIC Agency: Я сейчас буду детализировать и описывать это.
FANATIC Agency: Я больше сейчас фокусируюсь. На развитие новых продуктовых направлений?
FANATIC Agency: И в развитии оборонки и приключения для новых клиентов.
Diana Paritskaya: Как ты выбираешь в? Какие проекты ты включаешься в Какие Нет?
Diana Paritskaya: Которые?
FANATIC Agency: Который?
FANATIC Agency: Которые сильно через меня прилетают?
FANATIC Agency: Ну То, есть Прямо, там вкус Вел Услопна Либо Азбука вкуса это, проекта который. Просто.
FANATIC Agency: Пришли прям через меня и, там ребята ждут что я буду, навстречу?
Diana Paritskaya: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Т банк. Тоже так но, в т банке. На. Компании. В?
FANATIC Agency: Сразу переключились на качу, и, там, ну может. Быть, и, счастье, хорошо что. Ни. Команда, сменилась?
FANATIC Agency: И поэтому меня, там просто не ждуте, на каких встречах. Тогда все, как я понимаю, и не просишь чтобы Я просто презентовал?
FANATIC Agency: Вот все остальные. Но как вы имеете субъектность, знания, опыта для. Того чтобы, проект самотостоятельно затащить?
FANATIC Agency: Которые лучше не являются новыми а, Когда просто, чудо делаешь?
FANATIC Agency: Что никогда, никто не делал?
Diana Paritskaya: А когда вы вернетесь конкретикой повод новой системе там? Бонусные Вот? Этим всем вещам?
O!Sapiens Expert: Оптимистичном сценарии. Но Давайте это держать руку на пульсе если чего скажем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Если вдруг переносится научить более поздний период?
Diana Paritskaya: На пару недель. В смысле, через пару, недель?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Ну, Типу, вот, Сегодня?
Diana Paritskaya: Угу?
Diana Paritskaya: Окей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да для вашего понимания. Поросло в поводу того там, как мы взаимодействием синдромом. С Риной, Женей У нас естественно видели в календарях Встречи где, мы? Обсуждаем стратегические вопросы и какие тактические, решения там, будь то, по там документам оплатам, финансовом, планированию, приоритетом, с всяким схемам того как?
O!Sapiens Expert: Че. Там, с ипс, Ооо, И так далее чтобы, мы не ушли еще в глубокий минус с налогами?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но и какие, то, другие, стратегические инициативы будь то, маркетинг, или например, рассматриваем возможностям выхода, на какие к новые. Рынке с использованием и инструментов, и так далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но короче, к тому, что мы просто плотнее взаимодействуем с джейней ариной Для Решения. Стратегических. Вопросов?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нуи?
O!Sapiens Expert: Естественством все. Что, Касает, создание компетенций. И оценки и вот. Это всего также?
Diana Paritskaya: У нас время закончилось?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
FANATIC Agency: А у нас полчаса было?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Спасибо, А тогда давайте. Сделаем здесь перерыв. И?
O!Sapiens Expert: Скоро встренимся?
Екатерина Шалонская: Угу?
Diana Paritskaya: Давайте?
O!Sapiens Expert: Всего?
FANATIC Agency: Все. Большой. Дату. Лучшей встречи.
O!Sapiens Expert: Пока пока?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да, Антон, Спасибо, За сетерс, Я, Теперь В клубе должно, Быть?
FANATIC Agency: Ты. Вступила я. Сегодня случайно увидел?
FANATIC Agency: Ты мне ну не стало расскажешь потом, Что то, внутри?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да посмотрю?
FANATIC Agency: Кажется. Что, они хотят сделать?
FANATIC Agency: Замену транхантера В россии?
FANATIC Agency: Мы только войти по собирате ребята, которые, осматривают, сигналы чтобы?
Екатерина Шалонская: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Плат?
Екатерина Шалонская: Ну, Вот, жду, их?
FANATIC Agency: Что такое атексатель?
FANATIC Agency: Ты, материалы селина, Посмотрела?
FANATIC Agency: Престолы?
Екатерина Шалонская: Нет. Еще. Нет. Сегодня Собиралось Вот сяду после.
FANATIC Agency: Что интересное было, чем то, мне, сам вообще не стало.
FANATIC Agency: Лице, Я просто пересло смотреть?
Екатерина Шалонская: Мне, я потом?
FANATIC Agency: Давайте?